The subject of this segment is
the calculation of the PMF of
the sum of two independent,
discrete random variables.
This is the simplest example
of a function of two random
variables, a function of the
form of g of X and Y, where
the function g happens
to be just the
sum of the two arguments.
This is a very important
example, because there are
many situations where
random variables get
added to each other.
We work with discrete random
variables as a warm up.
And later, we will consider
the case of
continuous random variables.
So suppose that we know the PMFs
of X and Y and that we
want to compute the probability
that the sum is
equal to 3.
It always helps to
have a picture.
The sum of X and Y will
be equal to 3.
This is an event that can
happen in many ways.
For example, x could be 3 and Y
could be 0, or X could be 1
and Y equal to 2.
The probability of the event of
interest, that the sum is
equal to 3, is going to be the
sum of the probabilities of
all the different ways that
this event can happen.
So it is going to be a
sum of various terms.
And the typical term would be
the probability, let's say of
this outcome, which is that
X is equal to 0 and
Y is equal to 3.
Another typical term in the sum
will be the probability of
this outcome here, the
probability that X is equal to
1, Y is equal to 2, and so on.
Now, here comes an
important step.
Because we have assumed that X
and Y are independent, the
probability of these two
events happening is the
product of the probabilities of
each one of these events.
So it is the product of the
probability that X is equal to
0, where now I'm using PMF
notation, times the
probability that Y
is equal to 3.
Similarly, the next term is
the probability that X is
equal to 1 times the
probability that
Y is equal to 2.
Again, we can do this because
we are assuming that our two
random variables are independent
of each other.
Now, let us generalize.
In the general case, the
probability that the sum takes
on a particular value little z
can be calculated as follows.
We look at all the different
ways that the sum of little z
can be obtained.
One way is that the random
variable X takes on a specific
value little X. And at the same
time, the random variable
Y takes the value that's needed
so that the sum of the
two is equal to little Z. For a
given value of little X, we
have a particular way that the
sum is equal to Z. And this
particular way has a certain
probability.
But little X could
be anything.
And different choices of little
x give us different
ways that the event of
interest can happen.
So we add those probabilities
over all possible X's.
And then we proceed
as follows.
We invoke independence of
X and Y to derive this
probability as a product
of two probabilities.
And then we use PMF notation
instead of probability
notation to obtain this
expression here.
This formula is called the
convolution formula.
It is the convolution
of two PMFs.
What convolution means is that
somebody gives us the PMF of
one random variable, gives
us also the PMF of
another random variable.
And when we say we're given the
PMF, it means we're given
the values of the PMFs for all
the possible choices of little
X and little y, the arguments
of the two PMFs.
Then the convolution formula
does a certain calculation and
spits out now a new PMF, which
is the PMF of the random
variable Z. Let's now take a
closer look at what it takes
to carry out of the calculations
involved in this
convolution formula.
Let's proceed by a simple
example that will illustrate
the methodology.
We're given two PMFs of
two random variables.
And assuming that they are
independent, the PMF of their
sum is determined by
this formula here.
And we want to see what
those terms in this
summation would be.
Suppose that we're interested
in the probability that the
sum is equal to 3.
Now, the sum is going
to be equal to 3.
This can happen in
several ways.
We could have X equal to
1 and and Y equal to 2.
This combination is
one way that the
sum of 3 can be obtained.
And that combination has a
probability of 1/3 times 3/6.
And that would be one of the
terms in this summation.
Another way that the sum of 3
can be obtained is by having X
equal to 4 and y equal
to minus 1.
And by multiplying this
probability 2/3 with 2/6, we
obtain another contribution
to this summation.
However, keeping track of these
correspondences here can
become a little complicated if
we have richer our PMFs.
So an alternative way of
arranging the calculation is
the following.
Let us take the PMF of Y, flip
it along this vertical axis.
So these two terms would go to
the left side, and this term
will go to the right
hand side.
And then draw it underneath
the PMF of X.
This is what we obtain.
Then let us take this drawing
here and shift it to
the right by 3.
So the entry of minus 2 goes
to 1, minus 1 goes to 2,
and 1 goes to 4.
So what have we accomplished by
these two transformations?
Well, the term that had
probability 3/6 and which were
to be multiplied with the
probability 1/3 on that side,
now this 3/6 sits here.
So we have this correspondence.
And we need to multiply
1/3 by 3/6.
Similarly, the multiplication of
2/3 with 2/6 corresponds to
the multiplication of this
probability here times the
probability of this term here.
So when the diagrams are
arranged this way, then we
have a simpler job to do.
We look at corresponding terms,
those that sit on top
of each other, multiply them,
do that for all the possible
choices, and then add those
products together.
And this is what we do if
we're shifting by 3.
Now, if we wanted to find the
probability that Z equal to 4,
we would be doing the same
thing, except that this
diagram would need to be shifted
by one more unit to
the right so that we have
a total shift of 4.
So we just repeat this procedure
for all possible
values of Z which corresponds
to taking this diagram here
and shifting it progressively
by different amounts.
This turns out to be a fairly
simple and systematic way of
arranging the calculations,
at least if you're
doing them by hand.
Of course, an alternative is to
carry out the calculations
on a computer.
This is a pretty simple formula
that is not hard to
implement on a computer.